-This is -- This is
a fantastic idea for a film.
You are a speechwriter.
Charlize Theron
is running for president.
-Yes.
-At its heart, though,
it's a rom-com.
-It is a rom-com.
-Which is a genre that you have
been very open about loving.
-I love rom-coms.
-I do, as well.
-Yeah -- I-I-I-I--
I think love is a good thing...
-Yeah.
-...to put out into the world.
And I think, you know,
it's -- it's nice
to put out movies that are --
I grew up loving them.
Any -- Any movie
where a woman loves me
is personally affirming to me.
-Sure.
[ Light laughter ]
-So I like that.
But, yeah, I grew up --
you know,
"When Harry Met Sally..."
is one of my favorite movies
of all time.
And -- And we wanted to make
a movie that was truly romantic
but as funny, hopefully, as
any movies that are out there.
And, yeah, we worked hard on it.
And Charlize is hilarious,
and I think it turned out well.
-And it --
it is really fun casting
to see you and Charlize
in a film together.
Was that someone you had in mind
from the very beginning?
And was it hard
to get her to sign on
to the idea of doing a comedy?
-No.
She was actually really into it.
But, yeah, from the very get-go,
it was a script
that my company had,
and I thought
she would be amazing in it.
Traditionally, in films,
she murders people.
-Yeah.
-That's kind of her thing.
[ Laughter ]
And I thought
she would be funny, though.
And I'd seen her
on talk shows and stuff.
And -- And --
And I like to work with actors
who are a thousand times better
than me.
That's also a thing
that I try to achieve.
[ Laughter ]
It's not that hard to find them,
honestly.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-Do you feel
when you're with them
that you are elevated
by their presence?
-I am elevated.
But, yeah, I will say,
it -- it throws me.
It fully --
Like, I start watching it
as a -- as a performance,
and I start thinking,
like, "Wow."
[ Laughter ]
Which -- Which is not
a good thing to be thinking.
[ Laughter ]
But -- But I do.
It's like tennis, yeah.
That's what my wife
would always say,
is, like, when --
'cause I suck at tennis.
And she always pretended --
she claims she's good at tennis.
And whenever I play with her,
she gets mad at me
'cause she's like,
"I'm as good --
I'm as good as whoever --
as whoever I play with,"
and 'cause I suck,
I make her suck.
[ Laughter ]
And --
And I'm just like,
"Okay, whatever.
Sounds -- Sounds right to me."
But I subscribe to that theory
with acting,
so I try to act with people
better than me.
-You -- You were a producer
on this film.
-I was.
-And, obviously, you're in it.
So when you're a producer,
you get to sign off on things
like wardrobe.
You wear this windbreaker --
I think it's safe to say --
for like half the film.
-A lot of the movie.
[ Laughter ]
And was this just --
were you very happy --
when you saw the windbreaker,
did you know right away
it was the windbreaker?
-It was, yes.
-Yeah.
-I mean, even I was surprised
at how much of the movie
I wound up in that thing.
[ Laughter ]
I don't often have
strong character desires.
I'm a pretty easygoing actor.
I had one thing, and I was like,
"I see this guy
in neon windbreakers."
And -- And in my head,
I was like, "He'll look stupid.
It'll be, like,
a ridiculous fashion choice."
We shot the movie
like a year and a half ago.
And in that time,
they've become very fashionable.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-And the guy --
he doesn't look nearly as stupid
as I wanted him to.
[ Laughter ]
If anything, he looks like
he's on the cutting edge
of modern streetwear.
-Yeah.
-Which I did not want,
but I'll take it.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, it makes it -- Yeah.
-Now, it is gonna change
the framing of the film.
People are gonna be like, "Well,
that's a super cool dude."
-No, he was just supposed to be
a disaster.
And...
[ Laughter ]
-You had Boyz II Men
in the film.
-We did have Boyz II Men
in the film, yeah.
-And this -- I'm assuming
you're also a fan of theirs
in the way --
-Huge fan of Boyz II Men...
-Yeah.
-...since I was a boy to --
to...
[ Light laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Yeah. And they --
And they were --
I went to Bar Mitzvahs a lot --
a hundred Bar Mitzvahs probably
as a young Jewish boy.
And -- And -- And --
And that's when you first
really dance with girls,
and -- and you don't want to
dance to a fast song with a girl
'cause that would make you
have to move...
-Yeah.
-...which I didn't want.
And instead, I just wanted
to kind of like
hold onto a woman and sway.
And there was
no better opportunity for that
than Boyz II Men.
-Yeah.
-And you were,
like, just praying
a Boyz II Men song could come on
so you could
find the girl you liked
and just grab onto them
and sway back and forth.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-And so, because of that,
Boyz II Men reminds me
of my sexual awakening.
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
I bet you're not alone.
-Exactly.
-Yeah, I mean, they could've
called that -- their albums,
like, "Music To Sway To"
and every--
-"Music For Jews
To Get Little Boners To"
would be the perfect...
[ Laughter ]
-"You guys ready --
You guys ready to get
some little boners?
We're gonna put on
some Boyz II Men."
-"Little circumcised boners
out there!"
[ Laughter ]
♪♪ At the end of the road ♪♪
Yeah, it's -- yeah, music for --
for little boners to pop to.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
You're a -- There's a --
That's --
-They did better that they
didn't call their album that.
-Yeah, that's not -- Yeah.
-Probably, ultimately, yeah.